digital fashion is real and it exists in  so many virtual universes ranging from  basic social networks to a fully  developed Virtual Worlds known as the  metaverse because of my gaming  experience I kept thinking how and why  could people wear digital garments this  is when I started experimenting with  what today we know as digital fashion  with Carolina Herrera they collaborated  on a Runway dress and developed an app  where you convert the dress on your  phone using the augmented reality and  with John fogertier we collaborated on a  piece that was part of their Couture  collection fashion brands are selling  authenticated digital fashion items that  are usually sold out as soon as they are  released valenciaga has collaborated  with fortnite and Gucci bag was sold  inside Roblox for more than its worth in  real life  fortnite itself has sold more than 2  billion worth of skins and game extras  for in-game character dressing